what's your view on Hunting
um so you really hate poachers I really
hate poachers how do they operate who
are they what are they up to what do
they do
poachers to me are the people that are
going in and annihilating Wildlife for
profit without any
you know the people that are going in
and and machine gunning an elephant to
take its tusks yeah the people that are
sneaking into protected areas in Africa
and shooting rhinos
so they can cut off their horns before
the animal's even dead while its baby is
beside it
so and and there's a difference between
a poacher and a hunter
I'm a Hunter
JJ's a hunter I I work with an
organization called vet paw in Africa
and they use United States veterans who
have come back Post 9 11 Veterans who
have come back from the war and have
these skills
and they've been using these guys to
protect the last Black Rhinos white
rhinos elephants and so we've I've
gotten to see this play out on a private
reserve in Africa where
these incredible people have decided to
protect zebra's wildebeests all types of
Impala giraffes several herds of
elephants white rhinos Black Rhinos all
of this stuff is protected
and what's interesting is
it's a Hunting Preserve
and so
it's been very interesting and
challenging sharing my work there with
the public because for instance I went
to a very high profile photographer
recently and I said you have to get over
here and see this it's it's amazing what
these people have done it's this Reserve
called buffalo kloof and they've you
know there's this rescued families of
elephants and they have you can see a
black rhino every day if you want to
this is they're critically endangered
and it's because of the work that vetpod
does
protecting these animals from poachers
but what people don't understand is that
hunting happens all the time on the
reserve not for the elephants and the
Rhinos those are those are special and
they will never be hunted there but
things like an Impala things like an
Angela a wildebeest a zebra
there aren't as many predators as there
used to be so if you leave those animals
unhunted you know without the wolf to
chase the herd to thin off the ones that
are old and dying or sick
well then you just have animals that are
old and dying and sick walking around
suffering and so on reserves like this
they hunt
and they take the old ones and they use
the funding from hunting no one's going
to pay you thirty thousand dollars to
take a picture of a buffalo but they'll
pay you thirty thousand dollars to hunt
a buffalo
and so these reserves responsibly and
ethically on foot
can go hunting and manage and again if
they if they were hunting rhinos or if
they're hunting elephants I'd be out in
a second the hunting non-endanger
species they're hunting non-endangered
species a hunting game species and the
the difference is that a poacher is
gonna and so those are responsible
Hunters that are ecologists and
conservationists whereas a poacher is
someone that will come in and kill
recklessly
and murder an animal for no reason for a
part to sell
I would love to travel together actually
um so um let's let's we'll talk offline
I would love to make that happen if you
allow me I'm I'm 100 serious man I've
tremendous respect for your work and
I've been watching you since the
beginning I would love to do that
together
um
I've been
I've talked to Joe quite a bit about it
and I really
love the idea of eating the meat that
I've hunted it's mostly what I eat is
meat not for dietary I don't have any
weird constraints on my diet and so on I
just really enjoy eating meat
uh that's really good and uh there is a
part of me that's bothered by factory
farming yes sure that uh it's very
easily accessible to me but there's
something deeply wrong with it
um part of the reason I love fishing and
eating the the the fish that I catch it
just seems to be um more ethical but
also
a more intimate deep connection honest
connection with uh with nature you get
to see the killing of the food that
you're consuming versus
removing that from the picture not even
thinking about it not thinking about
that this came from the me and
um
yeah I love the idea that they get you
kill I kill one animal and they eat that
animal basically for the whole year yeah
an ethically slaughtered animal whether
it's a fish or a deer or whatever else
to me that's oh God how I'm gonna I'm
gonna use the wrong religious term here
but there's a there's a I feel like I
want to use the word like Sacrament but
it's like there's a there's a there's a
deeply
profound ritual
and and honestly honestly if you if you
teach a kid to grow a vegetable you show
a kid how to grow a carrot and the the
miracle of like wait I put a this thing
just grew in there it just appeared
because there was sunlight and it's like
yeah
the the
to me yes you that when you feel that
fish tug on the line
to me it it does something that that
awakens a deep Primal something this
satisfaction and then when you eat that
you feel you feel good and and so I
think the other thing like sort of
functionally speaking is that aside from
the fact that I think it's one of the
original
we're so disconnected like we should be
hunting we should be
Gathering walking more I mean look at
like what what we discussed now like
people are like oh you got to get your
steps in for the day and it's like that
never used to be a problem
um
you know people like well should should
we be eating animals and it's like what
do you think we do here on Earth like
I'm not sure how you got so confused
but Walmart did it to you like I don't
know like what I it living where I've
lived and I mean from 18 to 35 I feel
like I've grown up I've lived more
outside than I have inside and I've
it's just to me like showing people
these things I can see this miraculous
Wonder in their eyes when they when they
realize that they can reach out into the
world and interact with something and
and so when I hear these like frantic
people talking about you know whether or
not it's right it's like no of course it
is then again factory farming is is
awful but but I try to stay I try and
walk the line I'm worried about wild
animals I'm worried about wild
ecosystems
the other thing that's sort of
important about hunting is that if if
People's livelihoods depend on salmon
and elk and and ocean fisheries
well then they'll fight to protect it
naturally because it's part of their
life and it's if everybody's going to
Burger King and everybody's getting
chicken wrapped in plastic they forget
that the fish are there because they're
too busy watching sitcoms and so then
when the inter when the conglomerate
comes in and builds a dam
nobody really cares and then you just
end up with a few hippies and signs
standing next to the river and it
becomes silly
we forget the meaning